and mind you this was only two months
out of life
well what about this ulcer of mine Mr
Oakwood
I've been afraid that it might turn to
cancer but your stuff help that might be
cancer huh well now look there's one
thing you got to remember you see this
stuff ain't no medicine but then of
course cancer that's just another name
for a bunch of sales of the gone wild
you know because they're like but look
you give your body everything that it
needs
and themselves are satisfied
man life is not your condition is going
to improve
and you think by taking vitalife it'll
help oh absolutely
[Music]
now uh what did you say was the name of
your organization and the nature of your
lectures why do life Incorporated we are
producers of the miracle health food
supplement but in my lectures I stress
uh Better Health uh diets that sort of
thing it's very important for those of
us like you and me who are over 40 past
the prime of life as they say but with
proper diet and a mature attitude these
can be vital years well as the poet says
come with me for the best in life is yet
to be it's a wonderful sentiment don't
you agree yes I I see what you mean uh
you understand of course that we don't
permit sales of anything in our
facilities you do not permit sales
well believe me I am not peddling
anything this is basic education I am a
lecturer of course occasionally someone
wants to place an order for some of our
products while they're at the lecture
but I most certainly would not think of
turning this educational lecture into it
into a sales meeting be dreadfully bad
taste you know well just as long as we
understand each other certainly
certainly now just one more thing Dr
Wolf do you have any local references
well now really I did not expect this
question I am nationally known Mr
Greeley I'm sure it'll be quite all
right now if you'll just step into my
office I'll give you a receipt wonderful
wonderful
[Music]
you're invited to the opening lecture of
Dr Bernard wolf world-renowned Authority
on health and nutrition and president of
vital life Incorporated
well that sounds interesting
I better Flex this other literature too
you know it seems to make a lot of sense
people are far more conscious of diet
and vitamins than they used to be
say this might make a good story for one
of my broadcasts my sponsor has been
after me to get some new angles
bye darling
early tonight
oh you're late you know what oh what
Mike James asked me to the spring formal
oh Mike James eh well while you're
floating on cloud nine just float out to
the kitchen and put the food on the
table it's all cooked
that must be wonderful to be 16.
say this stuff is expensive
it could cost us about 30 a month for
our family
I know darling but that thirty dollars
might save us from a lot of doctor bills
remember how enthusiastic the Bennetts
were about how vitalife was helping them
but honey but they are selling this
stuff
oh but they weren't until it helped them
so much
well we'll see what Dr Wolf has to say
before we decide huh all right just that
we ought to do everything we can to
protect our health
well I've always been a healthy sort yes
and I want to keep you that way
okay Doctor you win hey what do we eat
right away
uh you know darling about the spring
formal it's only three weeks away and
it's the big party of the year for Helen
she really does need a new dress for it
I've just got to have a new dress data I
can't go in those old rags I've been
wearing all Rags what about the formal
we got you for the Christmas dance dad
that was a winner formal I can't wear
that
well what about the pretty blue one we
got your last four
I wore that one to the Valentine ball
honey I don't know now let's not talk
about it now maybe I can saw a new top
on the blue one and it won't really be
anything like that I'll just not go I
just won't
oh
don't let it upset your Ted it's just
that in Helen's age these things are
terribly important it would seem so I
don't like to say no to a Mary but while
money's a little tight right now and if
we take on this food supplement thing we
may have to economize somewhere else I
know but her health comes first
well we better eat if we're going to
make the lecture on time
[Music]
pepper
yes Mrs Aldi remember I told you about
it she has that gland disease that
nobody seems able to help
um
say we better find our seats the way
these people are pouring in
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm still like you good evening good
evening
thank you thank you
my friends I am deeply touched by the
warmth of your greeting I know it
expresses not only your sincere
affection for me but also your great
concern with me for the health of this
country and God Alone knows how
important it is to our future that we be
alert and strong and as we all know the
secret to health is proper nutrition
may I say as I look at some of you there
has been sufficient nutrition
now it is neither the quantity of food
so the fatty tissue that results from
overeating that gives us health and long
life
it is the quality of food and the
quality of food alone that determines
firmness of tissue and the roundness of
corpuscles
now then
just let us see what we have been doing
to our stomachs
these are embalanced
Little Pigs and you can imagine what
those embalming chemicals do to our
stomachs
now
see what we have here
you see what it is Water and Air
and we think this will support life
now this
foreign
[Music]
not much to them is there
well how could there be they've refined
out all the good and do you know where
it goes
to the cows and the pigs we get the
leavings and do you know why
cause we are Pawns
ponds of the large manufacturer and his
cartels
now then
just where does all this end
with this
with this instrument of pain and torture
used to administer the juice from
rotting putrefying molds Miracle drugs
they call them it's a miracle you
survive them
but we don't have to be victimized by
unscrupulous doctors in their medical
trusts
for even when they fail to help you
you can depend upon the most natural
cure in all the world provided for us by
God and all his wisdom
the Abundant fruits and vegetables that
make up correct nutrition
because I knew you ladies were concerned
with the welfare and health of your
families
I have collected here
105 preventative and remedial diets
diets for arthritis for cancer for
diabetes diets for high blood pressure
diets to restore glandular power
now
this guy's going pretty far
sell my book nor our wonderful food
s but if any of you wish to place an
order my associates will be on hand at
the end of this meeting
and I am sure you will enjoy alfalfa
sprouts in your salad they are Simply
Delicious and was the most interesting
lecture doctor well thank you I'm Ted
Hartman of television station ktvx I
wonder if I might interview you further
sometime well of course of course I'm
delighted to know you well perhaps we
could talk for a moment right here I am
sure these ladies would excuse us my
associates will be very happy to help
you
now then young man what would you like
to know what would you list as the most
important single element in human
nutrition kelp kelp absolutely you see
originally all life came from the sea
and in their primitive State our cells
subsisted on the nutrients from seawater
it's truly the mother of creation and it
still contains most most of man's most
precious nutrients today
but what about people leaving Inland I'm
sure my grandmother never saw kelp let
alone ate it true very true but that's
one of the great tragedies of mankind
the lifespan of the human race was
drastically shortened when it moved from
the sea fortunately though something has
been done
we have devised the means to process the
raw perishable kelp and extract the
vital juices in a crystalline form this
is something you developed well now I
could not accept all the credit but it
was from an idea I had after a study of
the Primitive Mori prabhman many of whom
lived to be 150 years old and there's
another very important thing about this
that's oh doctor I'd like you to meet my
wife Mrs Harper well how Charming thank
you we enjoyed the meeting so much
doctor well that's very kind of you now
as I was saying in my lecture after you
pass 30 the body begins to slow down and
and in some cases this is unfortunate
for marriages is that so well this too
is caused by the sterilization of
processed foods robbing them of all
their good
now if you were to fill your bodies with
high energy producing Foods as I
recommend in my book I am sure you could
even recover the zest of your honeymoon
oh that's very interesting well thank
you Dr Wolf thank you very much for our
most interesting and informative evening
we'll see you again in another lecture
it's auf wiederseus
Madame it has been my pleasure
good night goodbye goodbye
honey anything wrong
oh come on sweetheart out with it you've
been too quiet all the way home what was
that business you were giving Dr Wolf
about are not having any Vitality
neither of us is a teenager but I
thought that
you have to laugh at me
sweetheart does nothing wrong with us
believe me absolutely nothing
Facebook
what did you mean oh I was just letting
the good doctor talk leading him on
there may be more of a story here than I
thought
[Music]
your eyes thought that
well
never mind what I thought just glad you
didn't carry that gag any further you
Joker
[Music]
guys the what well that's what he called
it the medical trust and then he took
off on the juggish and the manufacturers
of food products claiming they were
poisoning the public I'm sorry I missed
it what's he selling well nothing he
claims but he was pretty blatant about
taking orders for his books
we heard about him through some friends
of ours who are peddling his food
supplement they claimed it would cut
down our doctor bills nothing I'd like
better
I don't think any food supplement would
do it
you got a couple more minutes sure
excuse me
operator this is Dr Glenn Hamilton
I'd like to place a call to Chicago
Whitehall for
one 500.
that's right thank you
I'm calling our American Medical
Association headquarters they keep a
pretty close check on things of this
kind hello
Bureau of Investigation please
hello
this is Dr Glenn Hamilton in Central
City
oh fine thanks
uh there's a nutrition specialist
lecturing here calling himself Dr
Bernard wolf
yes that's right
how you know about him huh
well I'd also like to refer a friend
who's a news commentator to some
authoritative Source regarding the
claims made by wolf
yes yes I know Dr Roberts
that's good
that's right I'll tell him
thanks a lot goodbye
you've heard of them all right
seems as though they've been keeping
pretty close tabs running for some time
they're going to send me a personal
information file on this burden you can
pick it up from me here I certainly
appreciate you going to all this effort
not at all it's a regular Public Service
of the AMA
meanwhile they suggest you call on Dr
Roberts at the University Medical School
he's a top nutrition Authority and also
a member of the Council on foods and
nutrition the American Medical
Association
they suggest too that you check with a
local Food and Drug office
all right I will and thanks very much
good luck on the story thank you I can
tell a skunk when I smell one
but these boys can give you its pedigree
this looks like it might be a long one
bye goodbye
what about bread doctor a white bread
step over there
now this is a demonstration I prepared
for a talk to some high school science
teachers
can you tell any difference in the rats
in these two rows of cages and the rats
in these two rows are changes no but why
ask me I'm no doctor well the point is
neither can I and I am
the rats in those cages were fed on a
special whole wheat bread containing
molasses salt honey malt caramel yeast
plus dehydrated vegetable flowers made
from carrot spinach kelp lettuce pumpkin
cabbage parsley and onions potatoes bone
meal and sunflower seeds you're kidding
no this is a special Health bread
marketed at about twice the price of
ordinary bread now these poor rats had
only ordinary enriched white bread well
I'll be darned I can't find any
differences neither can the scale nor
the rat what do you mean
here's a chart
wait General activity and reproductive
activity in all the rest see why do
people buy these expensive special Foods
there's a food fascism sweeping the
country it's a sort of a big lie
technique promoted by the people who
want to sell these things you can double
your food bill that way but not your
nutrition but where do these odd Notions
about food originate
man has always built up magic when they
felt insecure
here take a look at this
well this fine gentleman was also an
authority on nutrition I'm afraid he got
most of his information from his
grandfather however and neither of them
were very scientific about it
part of the Lion
we had the brain of the world for
cunning
[Music]
now this gal
this gal was worried about her
complexion
[Music]
of rare Beauty o Queen
to make your skin as smooth as a Lotus
Blossom
and may love attend you forever
[Music]
this guy could never work the same
territory twice he might have gotten
lead poisoning himself
whoa milk that's what it is Brothers the
most potent medicine money can buy good
for what ails you come on step right up
Jan what do you got to lose except all
your aches and pains come on get it
while it lands
what does it all add up to doctor fear
mainly fear mixed with Superstition and
ignorance
bad combination in anyone's diet that
sounds pretty serious it is
people who fall for food quacks often
spend large sums of money buying
so-called food supplements money which
could be spent more soundly if there
were to buy groceries which would
provide them with a balanced diet
now what about the relationship of food
to cancer we've been conducting an
experiment for some 15 years now on this
topic we may not know anything really
for another 20 years
any generalization that all diseases
caused by diet deficiencies are very
great and dangerous exaggeration and
some people find it so easy to be sure
quacks and charlatans have been preying
on the sick for centuries
the real danger is that people with very
real symptoms may try to cure them by
diet instead of going to a doctor for a
proper diagnosis
I can see how that might be I suppose
it's needless to ask if seaweed could be
the source of longer life oh that's
straight from the Bible of old Bernard
wolf well that's how I got started on
this story some of his ideas seemed well
to say the least exaggerated you could
have said distorted and it might have
been more accurate take this sea theme
of his for example now a lot of
legitimate research is being done on all
forms of sea life but that's a long jump
from calling it The Fountain Of You
I see a grain of Truth with enough
Distortion can become a gold mine
exactly well I've taken up too much of
your time already but thanks very much
for all your help you're most welcome
good day
sure we'll help anyone to educate the
public about quackery in any form how do
these characters get by aren't there
laws of some sort Society always
indulges the quack
I suppose because on the surface their
crimes don't seem so violent as
kidnapping or murder but when one of
these birds gets a hold of a patient who
could be cured with proper Medical Care
and as a result of that the patient dies
well to me that's manslaughter or even
murder
I never thought of it quite in those
terms before
are there many cases of it going that
far
yes we had one recently where a diabetic
was taken off insulin by a quack who was
selling cactus juice
the boy went into a coma and died
it was horrible what happened to the
guys selling the cactus juice well we
managed to put him out of circulation
but not all the operators are so easily
caught
how about this bite of Life out often
but you might be interested in hearing
how some of these boys operate
now these tapes were made while one of
them gave a Spiel now listen to this one
and you think my Taking Flight of life
will help me oh absolutely
well it sounds mighty good to me
what about my little girl
she's kind of crippled up
oh that's too bad
say you know ain't it a crying shame
that the doctors don't seem to be able
to help none now you take my little girl
why she'd had so many shots that she
looked like a pincushion
and they were probably causing a lot of
harm
but she was having some sort of spill to
some kind
and one night I was getting pretty upset
about it well at that very next night
the vital life people come to me and I
put my little child on the stuff and
from that day Mister to this
she ain't had no shots and she ain't had
no spells either
I don't know what's wrong with you
little girl but I know we love them more
than anything and we shouldn't keep what
they need away from them
that's fantastic it's hard to imagine
that they would stoop to praying on sick
kids
yes the little girl had leukemia and
it's a federal offense to offer for sale
any food supplement preparation as a
cure for that kind of disease
but it's difficult to get evidence for a
conviction
even when we do they usually get only
light sentences
I can't get over how sincere that fella
sounded but that doesn't make him any
less dangerous
sincerity or ignorance can't always be
considered armless when we're dealing
with human life
I wonder how big this racket is really
become we don't know but we keep a
constant check on it and so does the
American Medical Association and the
national Better Business Bureau but it's
like an iceberg only a small part shows
on the surface
excuse me
hello inspector Corley
yes I know the man
yes I would be interested thank you very
much
well it was a disillusioned follower of
wolf she just spotted her Fallen Idol in
a restaurant behaving like the rest of
us mortal
that I'd like to see no be good for my
story let's go
all right
[Music]
okay well
what is the meaning of this
I have no time to interview you right
now just a couple of routine questions
how many people have died as a result of
your treatment how many victims have you
left in broken Health what how much
money have you made from this racket
this is outrageous what right do you
have what about the rights of the people
you Swindle doc
who hired you I know your game you're
part of the plot of the big
industrialist and the medical
associations they're afraid of me that's
what it is they're afraid of the truth
what a cheap lousy crook
hide you think what you like
enjoy your embalmed carcasses I hope
they're all you say they are
[Music]
looks as if a lot of us have been
suckers
doesn't seem very funny now does it
that's all it was to it we could laugh
it off like Barton I don't feel much
like laughing
neither do I
[Music]
Mary this thing is bigger than the dope
traffic and involves a lot more people
people who can't afford the money for
useless pills and fancy food they need
it for milk and eggs for bread for meat
and vegetables the things that really
make kids grow just don't get it why do
we all fall for these phony pitches well
it's because people are afraid and these
bums play on the vague hardly
recognizable fears of average people
like you and me on the latent
hypochondrian that's all time people saw
the real story and learn how they're
being cheated
guess we don't need this anymore
[Applause]
you just watched a little homemade Magic
[Music]
yeah get Helen that new dress she wants
we just saved thirty dollars it'll need
more to other than those food pills will
anyway
[Music]
um
brother I've got some bad news for you
did you know that the food you eat no
longer contains sufficient nourishment
to sustain I've been out now don't be
alarmed because I have here in these
easy to take little crystals that that
miraculous new food supplement Mary
looks like we better call inspector
Corley again go on get out of here
you'll bomb feed it
[Music]
daddy you're the greatest simply the
greatest
thank you